All right.
Well, today, I am talking to Roger
Dannenberg, who is a professor of community
of Computer Science, Art and Music.
What a wonderful group of things to
be a professor of, by the way
at Carnegie Mellon University and he is
also a Trumpeter, a Composer and a
Computer Scientist, of course, and he's the
co-creator of Audacity, which is an extremely
popular open source digital audio editor and
recording application.
Roger, welcome to FOSSDA.
I'm so happy that you're willing to
chat with us for a while today.
So I'm going to just dive in
and say what was it that brought
you to working with an open to
creating an open source project?
How did you make the decision to
do that?
Well, the project started basically from research
needs that that we have that we
were working on actually on query by
humming, which was getting computers to recognize
tunes that people might sing or hum
and search a database for them and
part of that is just recognizing pitch
and tunes and we were working on
some algorithms to improve that.
And of course algorithms fail and then
when they fail, you want to see
what happened and we were trying to
visualize audio and the analyses that we
did and figure out what was going
wrong and we just felt like it
would be really great to have a
tool that could help us display audio
data in different formats and deal with
different audio files.
This comes up over and over again
in audio and music research and at
the time there, the tools that were
there, just, you know, didn't seem very
good.
They were either very proprietary and we
had problems, you know, moving from one
computer to another or they were designed
for a special purpose and we were
doing research and wanted something more general
purpose.
And so, you know, maybe it was
foolish to think that well, we could
just start from scratch and build our
own but that's what we did.
And yeah, and so the actually, you
know, I'm not sure that we ever
certainly I never made an initial decision
that "Oh, I want to build an
open source audio editor distributed in the
world and it'll become the most popular."
Yeah.
that It'll be the primary editor of
its kind in the world that just
never crossed our minds.
In fact, even, you know, at that
time which was around 2000, you know,
most people in the world didn't have
the kinds of computers or the kinds
of network connections and everything else that
you would need to even distribute something
like this.
So, you know, it grew out of
some, some very personal goals and needs
in a lab.
And it just it kind of happened
to be useful for some other things
and make its way gradually out into
the world and develop into what it
is now.
Is there a decision point that you
recall where you decided?
This is going to be open source,
and we're going to collect, you know
input from a lot of people.
How did that decision come about?
Yeah, a lot of from Dominic Mazzoni
who was a grad student at the
time and Dominic did did more of
the work than anyone else.
It was mainly the two of us
and I was contributing some kind of
low-level audio drivers that I had built
and and worked on some symbolic display
as opposed to audio waveform display, but
Dominic really put together the basic waveform
display and interaction.
And it was it was Dominic that
suggested in the very beginning that if
if we are going to build something
to display data , it really wouldn't
be much additional work to cut copy
paste and right, you know, and write
it back out to disk.
So you could, we could integrate some
basic editing functions and I thought, well,
yeah, it makes sense.
That's a great idea, but don't spend
too much time on it.
So that worked out and and then
it was really Dominic that that had
some particular ideas about, for example, using
the canoe license.
And, you know, sort of how things
would be organized and made into a
open source distribution.
I had previously done a lot of
software and made it available and not
never really worried much about licensing or
any of these details.
So I was happy also to get
the software out there, especially since we
incorporated these editing functions and we thought
it would be helpful at least other
researchers.
And so, you know that and then
the idea of a community and bringing
people in really came about after the
initial work.
We, you know, it was just us
and we were using the software and
released it the software.
And, but then later other people sort
of started using it and wanted to
make improvements and most of that actually
happened interacting with he was he was
the one that sort of pushed it
out there and he was the one
that people got in contact with and
and I had a lot of other
other duties teaching and researching and doing
doing my stuff back at Carnegie Mellon.
So I was, you know, it kind
of just evolved that way and then
because I was still a user and
I have written some of the software
and I was helping to do some
maintenance at at some point, you know,
much later in the game.
I kind of came back into the
group and started working much more with
the group and, with audacity.
So you said you'd developed other software
before.
Do you perceive a difference?
Given this was an open source project
from sort of other projects you had
done.
Like, did that change the character of
the experience for you?
Or what?
What was it about?
It being open source that that made
any difference.
Well, I think maybe open sources is
really an outgrowth and maybe I just
see it this way, but maybe it
really is an outgrowth of the academic
world.
Where in academia we do research and
you know, we get the rewards are
not so much money, but recognition.
That people want to want to be
recognized for being, for making contributions to
whatever field, they do research or public
or writing in.
And so, we publish, but we don't,
we don't publish, you know, and signed
book deals.
Well, actually, we do sign book deals,
but terrible deals, right?
We're lucky.
We're lucky to get anyone to publish
anything because dry academic stuff and, similarly
with journal articles, like, you know, in
some sense, we're professional writers, but we
don't get paid by the publishers.
Well, I don't know, if everybody knows
this or not, but if you didn't
know, it might be interesting that, you
know, these thousands and thousands of scientific
papers that get, published the author's, typically
get zero and, and, the publishers.
Many of the publishers are nonprofit organizations,
like communications for the associate.
I mean, the association for computing machinery,
the ACM, or IEEE.
These are nonprofit organizations.
So, you know, the point is just
to get the literature out there and
and share it and and then our,
you know, hiring and promotion is kind
of based on peer review and our
recognition in the world.
So, we don't get anything directly from
publishing and and I think software is
at least when I was going through
school and, you know, decades ago software
was kind of in the same category
as publishing.
People would write software, but academic publishing
people would write software and systems and
and they put it out there and
see if other people will use it
and that was just kind of like
a form of experimental science to see
what works and what doesn't and so
it seems it was almost unnatural to
me, to think about selling software and,
I do actually have a few patents.
The first patent that I got was,
essentially a software patent, which a lot
of people said "oh, you can't do
that" and some people said it was
wrong.
I felt like it was, I mean,
this particular patent, we won't go into
it, but it was unless you want,
it was you know for a very
specific invention and a very specific application,
that seemed to have some real commercial
use and the patent was actually key
in enabling it to be commercialized.
So, but other than that, you know,
most of the stuff we do, we
don't like, we never expected anyone to
pay for this audio editor.
There were plenty of audio editor products
out there that were available, but we
wanted to make something free that would
help people do the kind of work
that we were doing and we were
very fortunate to have some support through
other means, so we could afford to
do it and make it free.
Yeah.
Well, so for anyone who's watching and
isn't aware of it, I mean, Audacity
is basically on, I mean, I would
think on the top of every musician
and you know, audio editor and everybody
uses this tool.
So clearly it evolved from something that
was basically a research project to something
that had, you know, an incredible like
mass audience and users everywhere.
So as the project changed from what
it was originally to what it was
eventually.
Like how did how did the experience
of participating in the project?
Did it change for you at all?
When it like took a step up
and got so popular?
Yeah, I think I mean I learned,
I certainly learned some things from this.
And one thing, one thing I learned
just from observation was, is that Audacity
is very simple to use.
And I mean, some people would say
no, it's not really that simple but
compared to the kind of software that
people are using in studios that, you
know, really take some work to get
into and to get things done.
Audacity was deliberately made to be a
kind of what-you-see-is-what-you-get editor with direct manipulation
and very simple menu commands and all
of that stuff was there and on
purpose, you know, we talked about it.
And again, I have to give Dominic
credit for wanting it to be that
way because I think other developers including
me just trying to you know add
features I needed to do this.
Let's do it like this and then
you know, if you do that too
many times you end up with this
monster that nobody understands.
Yeah, and so Dominic was always kind
of the back pressure saying yeah, we
could do that.
But you know that's going to be
confusing.
What if we did it like this?
Or what if you know, or maybe
maybe we just shouldn't do that at
all.
You can do that, you know with
your own private extension or do it
with another piece of software or something
and kind of that attitude of, this
has to be really simple, so that
anybody can just download it and start
using it right away.
Really, it was a huge contribution.
And I think that's also something, you
know, maybe that open-source can do much
better than commercial ventures, which is that
and I've learned this from the commercial
side that products have to have features
and products in order to market products,
at least the belief is that you
have to have a long feature list
and you have to in order to
keep generating revenues you have to add
new features and the list, get longer
and longer and longer and the interface
is get more and more complicated.
And what we can do with open
source is safe, like we just don't
care about selling, you know a new,
improved version with more features to people.
We just want to make the most
useful thing for people to use right
now and if they like it, maybe
they'll upgrade in a few years.
And when they upgrade, you know, we'll
get a penny from advertising or something
but it just doesn't matter.
And so we can really focus on
what's important for users.
Yeah, that's that's great.
So was there anything about the Open
Source process?
Participation, you know participated in running a
project and so forth, anything that you
wish you'd done differently, or that was
a problem or a challenge and that
you figured out how to solve or
what were the downsides and how did
you and the team react to those?
Well, I think Audacity, you know, as
you said it was incredibly successful and
I don't think anyone could hope to
do something so successful, you know, by
design it just right.
I've, in fact, I've tried to do
multiple other things by design, if they
haven't worked out nearly as well, so..
And if someone came to you and
said, we're going to make this program
that's going to be wildly successful.
How do we do that in?
People would have just said?
No, that's not possible.
Yeah, so but some issues that have
come up.
I would say that the main issues
are getting people to work together.
I'm working and I haven't really touched
it in a long time.
And I went back to sort of
see look for other versions and see
if there are any bug fixes or
things that uou know, may have happened
on the side without me knowing about
it and sure enough I found like
a hundred different repos on GitHub that
had clones of my software and various
things.
So, one thing that's, you know, that
I've learned that's difficult, is to really
build a community of people that are
working together to support the some thing
and I'm not really sure how that
worked on Audacity.
Maybe it was just you know, the
luck of having having the right people
kind of sign up and also just
having some very generous people that wanted
to say "well I'm you know, I'm
not just going to take Audacity and
add some features and rebranded or something.
I'm going to I'm going to work
on.
I'm going to join the Audacity project.
I'm going to contribute to this one
project and make it good." And, having
so getting people to actually contribute instead
of just, you know, maybe take the
software and send you email saying you
should fix this.
You should fix that not putting any
time into it.
That's, I think that's a real problem.
So another problem is when you do
have people that are contributing and very
generous, you, well, at least with Audacity,
there was a team of people that
developed.
So it was kind of like an
inside, you know, it's as if you've
got the inside group that has kind
of all the power and all, you
know, carries all the all the decisions
and you have the outside group, which
you also hope is there, you know,
making contributions, but you know, the governance
of very loose volunteer organization is really
difficult because I think if it is
completely open and everybody has an equal
vote, then it's very easy to get
distracted.
You know, someone will come in and
just make a lot of noise and
maybe not have much to contribute but
it can be a real distraction.
On the other hand, if you have
sort of a core team that, that
team can you know, it runs the
risks of alienating other people or being
disconnected from other people.
And, you know, I think Audacity's had
some very generous people, you know, we've
often referred to Dominic as the benevolent
dictator, which is a good description.
You know, he really put his heart
into it and did a lot to
keep things going and made really good
decisions all along.
So, but how do you how do
you do that?
Or how would you repeat that?
It's I think those are some really
difficult problems.
Yeah, I think leadership matters, no matter
what you're doing, right?
And a big project, a lot of
what lots of volunteers can be very
challenging right?
Definitely.
Well, so anything else you want to
add?
Before we wrap it up a, anything
you want to that you're looking at
in the future or anything you want
to say about what your experiences have
been?
Yeah, I would I guess I would
say that.
I mean one thing that came out
of that, you know, that I learned
from this project, that might not be
obvious to people thinking about open source
is that there are a lot of
possibilities for generating income and one of
those is, you know, some of some
of the Audacity developers, did some consulting
on the side.
So they would, for example, adapt Audacity
for to be packaged with a product
or are bundled with a crime or
they would, you know, work with researchers
and get some money to add some
feature for them or something like that.
Another possibility is that, you know, when
you go and download software, you think
of it?
Oh, well great.
This is free.
And you might wonder if you thought
about it, you know, who's paying the
researcher, who's paying the electricity, and for
those servers like if we're downloading a
million copies of Audacity a month, that's
actually pretty expensive to provide that much
service.
You can't just, you know, run that
from home and so you might think,
oh, well, you know how could an
open source project even afford to do
that.
And part of the answer is that
depending on where downloads take place, most
downloading services run ads.
And so the downloaders will actually pay
for the privilege of providing the servers
to download your software.
It's not a lot of money.
So, and maybe that's a good thing
because if nobody's ever going to really
get rich off of it, then it
just kind of can help grease the
wheels and you know, pay for an
occasional machine or allow you to contract
out something that really needs to get
done that, nobody wants to do for
pay for a graphics designer or you
know, there's it gives you some flexibility
in a mostly volunteer effort, and so
anyway, those you know kind of the
business and money side is something we
don't normally like to talk about but
are and it gets tricky.
But it is real and I think
it's part of the story thats interesting.
Yeah, very interesting.
Well, thank you so much for talking
to me today is really interesting to
hear about the project and your participation
in it and And thank you for
all the work you did because I
love the project myself particularly.
So thanks so much for participating and
have a great day.
Yeah, thank you.
This has been great.
Okay, bye-bye.